along in the stash Creek I remember it
so you don't have to and we're almost
done we're almost done it's single musk
is almost clear we have one more movie
to review just one more I dunno maybe
they'll be good I mean for crying out
loud you can't always judge a book by
itself yes
Care Bears is another one of those
classics what the hell were you thinking
moment of nostalgia we all hate to admit
it but we did watch this lovey-dovey
and it has not aged well with
time the first film was bad but I give
it credit that at least it has some
atmosphere a decent pace the pretty cool
building this film
let's just get see more months over with
let's dive right into the Care Bears
movie to actually let me rephrase that
it's not the Care Bears movie - it's
just Care Bears movie - I guess the
words always just cramping the title
style and on top of that it's not just
Care Bears movie - it's a new generation
so really the opening should look like
this
[Music]
and
so as the credits roll we see this ship
in the middle of the ocean being handled
by a bear and a horse isn't it always
there taking care of a big bundle of
babies they're sleeping down below so I
guess this is the new generation right
actually no it's the exact same
generation they're just all babies now
well that would make this a prequel then
right actually no because the Care Bear
cousin's like the lion the penguin and
so forth they're in there as well even
though the first bills stated they had a
completely different backstory so I
guess the bear and the horse are their
parents right actually no because well
how the does a bear and a horse get
together and produce a lion a sheep a
penguin and God knows what else but I
met her how did she squeeze all those
little bastards out at the same time her
cooch must be hanging to the
floor and high what the are they
doing in the middle of the ocean with a
bajillion babies pretty fun even
over in this movie makes no goddamn
sense it can bear this should be that
hard to follow what I'm a creature with
no real origin pops up then dark we have
no idea what he is where he came from or
how he works but it's just evil whoo
you
[Music]
God are you tenors take the holy remote
awesomeness take the holy
rainbow awesomeness is that you Waco
eyes we'll find the circle gets an
upgrade or decorate and the camera
fender into care huh
as we finally people pulled them out of
trouble well done my little star and
hard buddies let me guess
we're never going to be told what that
thing is yes great terrific work what
five minutes in and already nobody's
idea what's going on I mean this new
generation isn't a new generation that
you've all been chasing oh we have no
idea what it is that creamy star face
you I mean why is it be the cool Care
Bears too which is no way continuing the
story from the last movie they're just
changing and halfway through it all the
little kids are praying their parents
are going to know what's going on but
me a McCune it's like doing Lord
of the Rings and as soon as you hit the
two towers the authors like their budget
let's make proto a porcupine ever born
will be an easy bake oven and so on the
Lord of evil is now being replaced with
a pencil sharpener
we'll never explain why but it
nobody will notice
I go our search is now over we have
found that the two creatures whose love
and tightness for others is so great
that it sets them apart from the rest of
the world by dragging these newborns and
ours dangerous waters you've shown just
how much you truly care for them the
considerate so we do find out that the
Cubs are orphans at least oh why an
orphanage is on a boat in the middle of
the water I have no idea and we're told
their ultimate purpose and as they have
helped them protective of little orphan
Cubs they shall help others to share
their feelings and protect everyone from
dark hearts evil Thanks curiously
nondenominational star God will enjoy
carrying out your incredibly vague quest
the other caretakers are now given the
name true heart and Noble heart and they
have the incredibly simple task of
making everybody in the frigging world
feel better um yeah you may want to look
into outsourcing curiously
nondenominational star God what am I to
do
thankfully only one set of teeth does
heavy problems in the whole entire world
and that's John dawn and Christy going
to the store that maybe some Afghan kids
we're feeling a little blue but no
Justin speedy free lucky lucky
you three are laugh at everything if you
can't keep up leave after you do the
trash dude yeah I always love those
camps that had no camp counselors and
only let the kids call the shots
things always turn out fair that way I
hate being last and I hate being here
he's right
he'll always be mad so Christy decides
to run away because she's not able to be
what she's always dreamed can you guess
what that is cam cam cam cam cam cam cam
cam cam cam down caption cap cap cap
damn camp champ I'm gonna say bitch the
other two kids decide to come with but
get lost along the way too hard comes
across the children and in typical Care
Bear fashion they never question why the
are talking bears and product
running away from a problem never solved
it you two are just too worried about
the things you can't do maybe you should
think about all the things you can do
like what let's stop it for notice I'm
making movies based on characters from
greeting cards they'd be a great thing
you can do some sugar it has a very
weird idea by taking the two kids to
their home and putting them to work
looking after the babies because child
labor is a sign of caring I guess
somehow it all works it's really not
give a little here everywhere god
there's only so much cute penis I could
take I mean tell me do they ship
sprinkles or Lucky Charms because
nothing else would make this crap
anymore small fee seriously any idea for
this anyway even the double cone think
of something so terrible yeah yeah
you're the devil
who else could do well ok fair enough
but what are you doing here well I've
come to explain this unholy abomination
that you humans called
real so you're the one who create a
carrot up how did you do that at Hollis
no critic
there are several subconscious messages
that are being planted in little
children's mind Oh what
well for example notice how the
caretakers leave the children behind
these two little delinquents looking
after them well this is a show that
being a deadbeat parent it is ok no
kidding
and imagining your children we can't
take care of themselves to be raised by
other children who can't take care of
themselves is the way of the future also
notice how the Care Bears always use
magic to solve their problems well this
is to show the little children that the
black arts are the path toward life and
should be used in more everyday
occurrences
they lure guitar Morpho conscious
messages like this do you have no
yeah oh yeah well your head looks like
it's coming out of a vagina right
this is sorry and speaking of devil we
get another visit from dark heart as he
talked to Christi by turning himself
into a building and just to make the
coherency in this movie even more
confusing only do the main two kids look
like the main two kids from the first
movie but dark heart is voiced by
Nicolas from the first movie and Christi
is voiced by the girl from the first
movie and the bishop wasn't confusing it
up already
you are the camp champ ain't you no I'm
not well you sure could have fooled me
who are you I have so many names you
wouldn't want to be the camp champ would
you I could fix it for you I don't know
there's only one catch though you're so
it's no big deal
sometime I'll drop by and ask you to
return the favor or you just do it no
person done goodies will come on and all
they attain this world so dark art makes
her dream come true and she's suddenly a
sports all-star by the way am I the only
one who think dark art sounds like the
Evil Dead demon where
soon they'll come with you where are the
things that were and shall be again all
night so much if they didn't steal the
continuity from the Evil Dead movies as
well knowing that it was only a matter
of time before dark heart poundin noble
heart and true heart moved the little
Cubs to a sacred place and seeing how in
a later scene to our car finds them
anyway this was completely pointless so
years go by at the Care Bears and Care
Bear cousin's all grow up into their
adult form give some hope to children on
earth never change what is there some
sort of space-time continuum thing that
care-a-lot is pulling off and this is
all once again a part of my plan I want
the whole time chain thing is part of
your plan yeah
you see when the room made that deal
with dark-hearted cause time to slow
down for her no doubt showing that a
deal with the devil has many persons an
offense like living brother if you would
like a saga soul today just a little
better-looking power glory or being the
camp champ all opportunities are open to
you ha remember that a pebble feet were
temp so yeah like I said before even
though they moved all the way to
care-a-lot dark heart finds them anyway
how only the baked mines or the writers
could answer that for you he quizzes
there to fix the caring year which it
turns out is really broken um good
timing I guess we're having a party
who likes game blind man brothers down
there and leapfrog is up there time for
a game of disappearing bears I don't
know why I really love the way he says
that one boy time for a game of
disappearing bears it almost sounds like
he's channeling Christopher Walken it
just cracks me up time for a game of
disappearing bears
so dark our plans to capture all of the
Care Bears together with a bag the Lord
of evil secret weapon is a bag hey
here's a crazy idea
um remember when it turned into that
giant killer dragon before um why don't
you just do that again I mean I know
it's not as subtle as I'll bag but I
think it would still be much more
effective we're terribly sorry and we
give you a hand
[Applause]
[Music]
no down here keep your tiny little
security down you're hard so darkk art
shows off his real form but luckily true
heart and Noble heart are there to lead
the attack against it you have won today
but so noble heart and true heart tried
to track him down and defeat him once
and for all leaving the rest of the Care
Bears to look after the air but dark
heart goes back to Christie - Eska Desna
Stabler she promised in I want to trap
the Care Bears and I have a plan
the world must learn to fear me ah I'm
sorry Evan thing is make along the whole
telling this isn't dark heart it's odd
and what if I refuse to help you what
then do you want to go back to being the
little girl who never want anything the
one who always came in last no yes it's
either help the Lord of Darkness rule
over Europe or be p-p-poor in sports
don't make her too so of course like an
idiot she agrees and they go riding into
the night come now we are wasting time
hey does a lot like those Twilight me no
it's not what's compared to that shared
so Christie and Doc I plan a trap for
the Bears by making it look like she's
stuck in a canoe um is this really a
chair bear related matter I mean it's
not like she doesn't care that she's in
the canoe
yeah you got to use this little
bag I guess I can make a handy weapon if
you force it on the scenario it's dark
arse
you mean ah hot well we can't just sit
here we have to help that little girl
secret bear and I saw her throw her
paddles into the water she's working
with dark art she you got why so glum
Kristy you're doing a great job there
will be no one left to stop me Wow ha ha
Plus isn't it luckily Chrissy has a soft
spot for 18 explosive darkness you saved
me
right you're still a person you knew
what was good for you would have left me
yeah I hate to admit tripping and
hitting your head on a canoe it's a
pretty funny way to go for the ruler of
all you what's that he hit his head on a
canoe and drowned
oh I can't believe we were actually
afraid of this guy well let's break out
the peppermint schnapps so just like the
first build ha ha
turns all the people in the world into
jerks we've Christy's hello dark heart
had trapped almost every one of the Care
Bears and Care Bear cousin's
oh I mean did she really keeps calling
for help of those fuzzy little idiot
kept going after her
how many times do you fall for that each
time we go to help someone in trouble
that someone could be Kristy setting
another trap hey here's an idea why
don't you just not go after Kristy I
mean this is really simple if you hear
her screaming just don't go art
that interesting them Oh somebody help
me
me Oh pick it out of the situation
whatever it is oh I am save you all
oh my got a bag so the Care Bears get
the two kids together decide to put a
stop to da ah evil we in the bed is
hideout which conveniently enough
happens to be right at the campground
[Music]
there's three parts ignore oh we thought
it was something else
lutely going to skeletor's workout
basement only to find a job God is there
winning now I have you uh you can't keep
us in here dark heart
oh I don't intend to I have a very
special place all set but that would
keep until after I've rest yeah I guess
the Lord of Darkness is sleepy come on
you think you'd be more awake for the
destruction of his mortal enemy but that
little star and hearts come in to pick
the locks good work
oh no little star buddy can't unlock all
these doors you're right
and we don't have much time well when
you're thrust you got a doc tool
no they go to get the key from around
his neck
I think he's changing shape as he
snoozes any logical person would just
squash the bastard one either frog but
can we be caring enough oh the plan
backfired as he banishes all the Care
Bears it's a little red Christmas the
kids show up to see the evil give duck
Christy included and the caretaker show
up as well the time has come to put an
end to your evil trickery ah who's that
you complaining ah so quick to get
zapped imagine to use her marbles and
get the chandelier down
[Music]
the good things you knew that would work
and not shatter than the to a million
bloody pieces how I died no really what
have I gone i I don't know what this is
help me Care Bear we can't it would take
more long than to carry then even we
have if you can't help can notice you
crave ivory care we all really care if
all of us and everyone everywhere all
care together
it just might be enough to save Christie
and when we say everywhere we may
specifically the feud alligators that
were desperate enough to show this film
we can if you have ever cared we do it
now everybody tell us you can tell your
friend looks to you that you can tell
them how much you can tell them again
say
[Music]
we can I believe is saccharide what hold
on
sorry um for that it oh okay
kidding bears I know the feeling i I ya
know just out of curiosity double sage
What evil underlining message where you
try to get across here more abortions
what this is Arkham any abortion yes I'm
actually surprised you don't see the
connection really you see the girl is
like the fetus and the Care Bears are
like the scalpel okay nevermind let's
just get through this now of course
Chrissy comes back to life despite your
inevitable empty silence and everything
seems to be all right
[Music]
okay that didn't happen but they do
escape in time and find that everybody's
okay I'm a boy
a real boy okay so it turns out the evil
health bought on his time just wanted to
be a real little boy who knew hell maybe
even Pinocchio had a similar backstory a
real boy
select Care Bears movie to a new
generation and can't believe I'm saying
this but it's not as good as the
original and of course the first film is
best but it did have a three-act
structure and some understanding of
character this movie's just a mess and a
ball outside of maybe the kid characters
no one in this movie has given enough
screen time to build any character
development I mean even very basic
development the story's all over the map
that it was not just rehashing the first
movie again of course there's a million
confusing problems about the basic
origins of these guys it's just a wave
lame move all these sequels were lame if
I had my way I have eradicated from my
memory I can make that possible really
you can it is totally within my power
that'd be wonderful go ahead and do it
powers of darkness by the minions of
hell oh all right do you really have
with the devil huh
the devil did you really think I was a
devil I was like that this costume at a
freaking Walmart oh here you're not the
devil but no no uh shame again give you
everything to get rid of these sequels
everything yeah everything um
congratulations you passed the Arden not
the devil
test you passed with flying colors Susan
I was just test you to see how strong
your faith really was how does that work
never mind anyway I can remove all these
memories of these bad sequels
and all you have to do is wire every bit
of your money to my PayPal account Wow
so from my memory oh yeah yes I can feel
them perishing from my mind
incredible oh my god maybe I am the
devil
[Applause]
[Music]
the Sun on my eye on my face I'm ready
for a party any time and safe and proud
heart captain don't never want to say
buddies perfect in every way
time for a game of disappearing bear